it's et's late-night roundup your quick
catch up on all the most buzz worthy TV
scoop after dark
[Music]
after more than a dozen years at FoxNews
I have decided to pursue a new challenge
just hours after megyn kelly announced
her departure from Fox News to start a
new journey at NBC the journalist opened
up about her decision on Tuesdays the
Kelly file and revealed she'll be
leaning the cable news network at the
end of the week I am very grateful to
NBC for this opportunity and I am deeply
thankful to Fox News for the wonderful
twelve years I have had here I have
grown up here and been given every
chance a young reporter could ever ask
for
thank you for watching with love over on
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert Oprah
Winfrey was a guest after years of
hearing her do her signature welcome
Nicole Kidman she revealed the celebrity
who originally inspired it John Travolta
was on my show many years ago and I said
coming up next John Travolta and it just
sounded so good please welcome our favor
[Applause]
meanwhile James Corden started The Late
Late Show off on a reflective note st.
tribute to the late George Michael who
died from heart failure on Christmas Day
the iconic singer was the first star who
agreed to ride in a car with cord and in
2011 as part of a bit for charity the
segment eventually evolved into carpool
karaoke when we started the show here we
were trying to get people to do carpool
karaoke and not many artists wanted to
do it and we would send them this clip
of me and George and we sent it to
Mariah Carey and she was the first
person to say yes and her words were if
it's good enough for George then it's
good enough for me I'll do it